boot Lake H podcast special guest in
here cam Archer back to tear [__] down
yes sir one of the hardest in all the
Cali let alone in his City facts who do
we have up here from San Bernardino we
had a few people up here oh I don't even
want to talk about it but yo let's just
let him do what he does come on man yeah
let's
go we going to just go through some
stuff this you know this is lyrical
exercise how I work out I'm fat you know
what I'm saying so that's how I work out
all right doing a lot of premere today I
didn't even realized that till just now
okay yeah shout out to AB shout out DJ
Premier
yeah
look stamp my name in the anal it can
never be replaced my DNA off the chain
I've already La the race asked God for a
sign he told me get on base congruent
with HR I ain't hearing no complaints no
disrespect to y'all for my brother in it
walls Behind Bars no Archer will forever
go yard like Undertaker with the fly
slug my God is substance I Supply you
suckers keep trying to reprise but I get
flyer from it told the mirror either die
or do the [__] most the Ali in a
saling sanging SGA quotes would take a
speedy Stevie Wonder to hit higher notes
I'm the goat forc the Ops to face it
they've been predisposed can't show a
crack in the armor I always recompose
body blows till apologies all decomposed
but save the sories for the brush pass
my Lush track record painted this plush
Landing Pad ain't my brush vast was down
bad now take bags with my corrupt cast
my luck crash now my kenel cracking like
we signed dzz we all dogs they spell
wrong you dyslexic I'm too impatient
with the weight it doesn't matter the
metric we here my mind for real
collapsing I traded passion for
recension to escape the detention when
all the fire's rapid better than
snapping calling family the in the cabin
it carry twins that's quick to sing and
leave your edges Jagged there's got to
be a better path rather than this me
thinks the recluse with no fuse is do a
Cuban Link flamb booy in his Frank Lou
and his newest mink transmitting like
Goku making they s ring still
competitive so my one rort to any list
reported without Cam must be a quarter
short shooting from the half as if the
court is short act as if that flag go
save you try to bang and lose your
oxymoron from your life support I'm
going catches catch can with demons call
storms and leave them to call xman
scatter brain but rescue and never been
the game plan you saving hoes with the
bread like it's powdered toast man I'm
special almost mad it took so long to
recognize it my Lo of reflection nearly
made me jeopardize it history I'll
rewrite it watch museums I it make a
killing overseas till they got a
extradited they impression hiding oh
there is no Collective rer and
ironically there isn't one that borders
suicidal like mine do fine to I'm fine
tuned if I do pass no my title scrapped
I'm good with that I don't got to rap
but we rapping today though woo yeah
let's keep it
moving oh you got sting right there you
know what I'm saying that's perfect
actually you got the sting shirt on yeah
yeah let's just bounce yeah [__] get
off me got a few G started Killing Them
Softly more enemies no need they lost me
kill them for the audience y'all Prince
Joffrey white girl bie don't start it
all that power no as lson my main girl
ass out of this world with the blicky in
her skirt like Marvin the Mar Way all
black fit like the crow now P Valley
script bro can't put the PO down flip
like Quest it's time for The Showdown
[__] he him those the [__]
pronouns FS get M down then she robounce
W like mown her name can't pronounce
pretty sure she came from like L the
wing your head game is danger stays off
Kanga every song made is classic janaa
big bro going up five you L Banger Flex
full time I hired a few trainers don't
sign [__] to F on retainer y'all knew
the boy was coming back in the manger
Slide Five Deep like the original
Rangers my ogs were still providing the
can by the train when the mayor was
speaking bringing my name up wait I got
big street shark energy uh whole gang
wavy I'm the centerpiece her they live
off my identity so I ain't tripping over
minies no flows I'm up to like Infinity
W my money baby should be printing me oh
pretty blatant how they stick to me I'm
griffindor you know to stick with me Law
and Order ho you see my intent see a
floating that's a current event amazing
how this [__] flirted with death just
to come back a better version again I
was hidden for a month on the low now
she in your DMs like a virgin again
Ghost Face home I'm home to murder again
the king with white he likes a bonus my
friend no we going to keep going
yeah let's rra it up strong shout to DJ
Premier yeah I'm like I'm really really
good at this indeed look tell these
[__] get smart they can't come up
short when they a bone apart work of art
standard checks kinetic like a magic
card Gambit Mark pressure carry baggies
like a shoing cart cop and stars like
the Lucky Charms box they remarks
usually Miss bases they face on screw in
most cases where my flowers you [__]
I'm still waiting for arrangements to
display brought in Array of brand new
vases smothered by pillow cases for
pushing a blanket statement you kidding
me right I Haun Slumbers [__] you
thought it was merry at night went from
Small Wonder to a mirror of Optimus
Prime big machines loaded make a puka
chain out of a spine that's a large
warning if you honing on something of
mine shooter the biggest stepper yet
quiet with light feet prpt on a come up
now fun coming at light speed hide it
I'm paranoid it could go with a light
Breeze [__] I look like with money
phones on IG they disconnect that
service where I'm from find your land
and line you up you see how messy [__]
become to my depression cancer come dog
my mama seen enough used to make the
rice with chicken grease 13th [__] is
Health we got to eat stuck in hell but
all it took was Lucas to make life
complete Kool-Aid in a ziplock for a
[__] thinking [__] is sweet you can't
game a shark My Level can I be secure
with cheats catalog and got to leave the
sheet to see the growth the leite I'm
sitting cozy in my skin they listen
closely your nose was up but that expose
your chin you're getting folded cuz oh
we only known for making hits I went
through hell unscathed El gu for the
face of this [__] they say he arrogant
well guilty is charge my high horse
going to have a Porsche chilling in the
garage on guard ain't it bizarre
couldn't get a retweet now your ex want
my face in her box like a trading card
talk my [__] like 50 I never back down
I'm Godly I got the right to vocalize
who wh now wa PSA I'll never be called
trash by a [__] still performing with
his vocals in the background talk I'm
absurdly hot my random verse drops held
up like like a jersey swap you Dill
Brooks I'm K Irving come earn my props
they want the shooter out of ammo
there's more in stock same b day as nip
she want the Ling spot but ain't support
when it was grocery shelves I stocked
I'm thinking death on the way if my
haters had a say but my vision board
Cyclops all you see now is C shooting
his shot then CC it to a Kuma your block
they see seeing but the rning must stop
keev this could be a regular thing cuz
smart mark saying last time was Austin
the King of the Ring announcement of my
arrival the foundation is heart put a
bulldog on your mug if you owing me for
the art don't see the appeal man I was
technical from the start get taper for
them remarks while you slacking we
looking sharp miraculous tractions get
tied captured and cut short told her if
I hit when we link what would I C for at
least my brother's game I ignore that
[__] would have had her blade pressing
like a cutting board Doo D and the city
see me like a Megazord him in real life
what the [__] would I go metaphor rather
talk my life than hiot in metaphors keep
it a buck I'm making change [__] [__]
know your timing is up cam [__] the
Heart Foundation uh yeah I did that just
for you that was amazing I did that just
for you that was amazing I got I got to
listen to that again cuz I was happening
I was like oh
[__] good [__] cam Archer go follow him
what's your IG man man uh cam Archer c a
r c h e r on everything follow me
everywhere go follow go support the
music go stream all that uh appreciate
you pulling up man thanks for having me
yes sir fire hey you just watched
another freestyle brought to you by the
good Folks at LRG goddamn it shout out
to LRG all right go use the promo code
bootleg right now on their website
l-r-g.com save 40% off at checkout 40%
off at checkout use that promo code and
we got another freestyle coming ASAP